all right how do you get really good at
coding
let's boil it down a little bit a lot of
you guys seem to have asked me stuff
like this
and uh I want to try to simplify it down
and give you some some useful answers
it's a hard question to answer actually
but you all already know the answer
that's the thing step one
the the main thing you gotta do at least
for me I'm gonna speak for what worked
for me I don't know what's going to work
for everybody and I don't have all the
answers I'm not some
Guru on the subject if you will
but I can say will work for me and it
was basically just having an end goal
that needed
a means to an end I mean programming and
coding think about it is a means to an
end we'll really just use it to build
things to do things to do work
so you need something that you want to
accomplish
you need some work that you want to do
to build to that
Tabby my friend Tabby will attest to
this right
so I can say for me it was the desire to
want to make games and tools for games
that really got me going
and C plus plus seemed to be the best
way to do that
that's why I started learning C plus
plus
and obviously I need to get good at it
if I'm going to do it well so that was
my goal was to basically get good at C
plus plus and start trying to make stuff
so I guess that leads me to step two or
tip number two
study hard work hard try hard and make
stuff at the same time so you need to be
going through some kind of course that
you need to be going through some kind
of learning scale all right if you don't
know something look it up
we have the internet
look it up you can look up anything
you can answer you can get answers to
about any question you have especially
on little technical tools they're out
there
if you want tutoring for me you can sign
up on the patreon and I can uh
I'm happy with that
I gotta get this on camera
I got some coffee
this is smitten's the kitten please
adopt smittens someone adopts smittens
smitten needs a home
I'm being Smitten by this kitten
so yeah for me what I ended up doing
because I didn't really know what to do
exactly I didn't know how to start but a
lot of people in that situation because
I started a computer science degree I
basically dropped a lot of my other
hobbies and said forget everything else
I'm getting this degree I'm learning the
stuff the best I can
because I have a goal and uh
and this is how I this is how I start
this is how I get there
or this is at least how I start to get
there
if I'm not gonna you know I didn't
expect to get there in one degree but
all right smittens you're in my way
all right and I don't know about you but
for me I have a lot of respect for
anyone that's trying I don't it doesn't
matter to me how good they are it
doesn't matter to me where they are
if I see someone actually trying and
actually going for it
it inspires me
so I would encourage you to do the same
I know in a lot of situations you don't
feel like you could do it and that kind
of stuff we all feel that
let me tell you we all feel that
and and it's sort of true I mean maybe
you can't but you can start taking small
steps to get there you might not know
how to do all this stuff but you could
figure out a few things and then you can
come back again tomorrow and you can
figure out a few more things
and eventually you'll climb the mountain
that's that's the theory
so yeah have some kind of learning plan
don't give up keep going for it you will
get there eventually you're just going
to have to trust in that
all right I guess I'm gonna go for tip
number three this one's a little weird
not even that related to code
necessarily and it's basically
double down on the things you know are
right
Double Down
and get rid of the things you know
aren't right it's gonna be hard it's
gonna be really hard at least it was for
me
now I think you can kind of take this
with a grain of salt you don't
necessarily need to cut off
every single thing some of you just
might need to be toned down
like uh I love video games at all but I
can only play them so much so I have to
limit myself
to some point otherwise I'll just play
them too much and
you know and that that's it's a weird
dichotomy at least for me because video
games are basically the reason I started
coding
so why would I give them up you know
it's kind of a weird thing
but
they're a huge time sink so that can be
a problem so you've got to kind of
address these things carefully however
there are some things that you know are
totally useless or maybe that's not the
best way to say it but you know don't do
you winning any good and those
definitely I think need to go
dare I give specific examples on that
I don't know maybe I should maybe I
shouldn't
um I don't know for me I guess that you
know I had some old friends that why
they were cool and all and fun to hang
out with and maybe hilarious and we've
gone along well the reality was well
they didn't really want to do anything
other than like sit around and smoke
cigarettes and drink beer and like what
what does that lead to where are you
going with that
that doesn't really work well for growth
and development
so yeah that's uh that's kind of where I
learned to
kind of Double Down spend more time on
the things that I know I want to do
and there's you know everybody I guess
has you probably know deep down inside
of what it is it might be hard to admit
because maybe you have friends or family
that condone the whole thing or say you
can't do it and that kind of stuff and
those are the ones to watch out for
those are people you know you need to
get rid of when someone says something
like that at least for me that's always
the final straw
and the crazy thing about it is it's not
even that they're wrong it's just that
they're in this anti-growth mindset I
don't know if I want to go into too much
detail on this one I don't want to get
too personal but you know you know the
type of people I'm talking about they're
the ones that kind of stay stuck
themselves and it's almost like they're
talking to themselves saying they can't
do it but you know in your head what you
can do and what you can't do and you
know maybe you can't do it right now
like I was talking about earlier but you
can take steps to get there that's the
really important thing to know is
is that it's not that they're wrong it's
just that they don't understand how to
climb steps but if you know that it's a
possibility one day you understand how
to climb steps
and
you're different you don't need you
don't need that
it's not going to help you
and they're probably not going to do
anything but drag you down
all right
a few more tips I'm just going to ramble
a little bit here maybe you guys would
find this interesting maybe or not I
don't know but just another thing that
really helped me a lot and it
and this one was probably the hardest
and probably still is to this day it's
basically to cut off drama I know this
sounds crazy
because you guys probably see me as a
somewhat dramatic person from being on
YouTube and occasionally like blasting
people and stuff like that but that's
kind of this comes with the territory I
basically do it to cap off an end when I
do something like that it's the end for
me you know that's that's the end of the
story I don't deal with it anymore
this is another really important thing
to realize is that once you're an adult
you can't really teach people right
people can learn from you but they have
to want to if someone's like kind of
toxic around you you can't just teach
them to treat you better they're always
going to be that way until they change
and you have no control over that so the
best thing to do is get out of that
and it's it's pretty hard but
that's the reality of the situation and
you'll find you'll find good ones there
are a lot of good ones out there I've
met a lot of you a lot of you've met a
lot of really great people and still
friends with a lot of great people but
the ones that
weren't or don't
they have to go
and this this is how you
get good at things this is how you build
yourself up at least I believe that now
I'm not saying this is an end-all be-all
I'm not trying to sell you anything I'm
just saying this is what works for me
that's that's all so I just want to make
that clear
all right that's probably the most
important thing there is to just realize
like how important your time is how
important your flow is you have your own
flow you don't need anybody else to
really tell you it
you have it it's naturally inside you
you just kind of gotta hone it and work
on things day to day
and and just just realizing that you
cannot teach people
this was huge for me especially as
someone who tries to like teach code but
that's not even what I do I've realized
I realize I just kind of show processes
and whether people learn from it or not
I really have no control over it's
totally up to them whether they do that
and it's the same way with how people
treat you and how the people you
surround yourself with you notice
someone that's
sort of consistently that way and you
say hey I need to change this they won't
they can't they probably can't they
might try that's different I guess you
know like I said it's up to them so
maybe they can but once again it's not
something you have control over so
whether they do or don't
isn't up to you I still think people
should be honest and should be open
about saying stuff like that about uh
you know kind of respecting time and
boundaries and that stuff that kind of
thing but when someone shows you that
they don't or won't
that needs to go because you're never
going to get anything done you're never
going to build your life up to where you
want to be
if you keep listening to those types of
people and keep following those types of
people
we're gonna keep being around them
because I do believe it is true that you
are who you surround yourself with
all right last tip and this is probably
the hardest one for me
try not to spend too much time on menial
tests you're not getting anything out of
yeah there's a there's a difference for
like entertainment and you know
relaxation time
but there are a lot of things like for
example this video right here I could I
could spend days and days editing this
and it ain't going to get much better
it's probably just going to be better in
its roll form in the end
like all these weird intricacies of you
see in this hanger in my router that's
going to be way more interesting than
any edit I could put into this video
so I could I could literally put 40
hours working on this video editing it
but it's a complete waste of time
because it's not even going to make a
difference and probably just going to
make it worse so be careful what you're
spending your time on once you know what
you want to do just get it done the best
you can and move on you gotta
release it put it out there that's super
big too I this was really hard too I
know a lot of us work on little projects
here and there and we don't put them out
but once you have something you're proud
of
make a little front for it don't be fake
say hey maybe this is whatever I spent
this you know
a little Preamble of like I'm new with
this can make a big difference if you
know your project is not very good
because then people will at least you
know view it from that eye of okay
you've only got 10 hours experience or
something you're not you're not a
professional I get it but hey this is
not they might say something like hey
this is not bad for where you're at and
that's that's what you need you need it
this is not bad for where you're at you
can't always be perfect
so be real careful about that I hope
these tips help you guys I hope you uh
have some good growth and learn a lot in
2023
don't take everything here
exact as I do do it your own way you're
probably better at this stuff than me in
some ways good luck with everything
let me know what you're working on let
me know your goals
um
jump in the Discord if you want if you
want to do some one-on-one stuff join
the patreon there's a 50 tier to get an
hour session with me if you want me to
help you with anything so
take it easy guys I really appreciate
you all the supporters
and uh everyone I've learned from